fait
paris
o o
sam et loire où j'ai 36 ans j'habite au
tampon donc je suis le seul coutelier
forgeron de l'île de la réunion
donc je fais ce métier-là depuis
maintenant trois ans officiellement ce
qu avant je le faisais pour ma passion
elle même c'est beaucoup de patience de
recherche et fort voire 100 soit il faut
vraiment aimer ce qu'on fait quoi moi je
fais quasiment pas de croquis pas de
dessin soit vraiment spécifiquement
quand on me le demande pour des clients
pour des des réalisations personnelles
spécifique pour les gens là je fais des
croquis des desseins spécifiques sur
autocad ou autres et après que je
reproduis mais sinon je forge et je
laisse la simpar plaît on va porter
l'acier à une certaine température en
fonction de justement des
caractéristiques de ces patients là en
forge
donc on va le forger à savoir que plus
on chauffe l'acier plus on va le mettre
longtemps dans la forge plus diverses
des carburants donc il faut travailler
vite pour donner rapidement la forme au
couteau pour justement que l'acier
garçons maximum de qualité moi j'utilise
entre dix et quinze dossiers différents
pourquoi parce que chaque acier a une
caractéristique spécifique
une fois la lame forgée mise en forme
qu'on la laisse doucement dans la cendre
finançables dans la forge elle-même pour
baisser doucement température ensuite
vient l'étape de la mise en forme du
couteau les moutures c'est à dire on
fait le tranchant une fois qu'on voit
que la ci est bon à être trempé là on le
donc soit l'os ou à l'huile ou soit les
deux ça dépend là j'ai repris le couteau
traditionnel réunionnais que tout le
monde connaît pour un petit couteau
comme ça faut compter entre 5 et 8
heures pour le fabriquer entièrement un
bon couteau de cuisine ou un bon service
à couteau on peut le transmettre à son
enfant qu'il retransmettra son petit en
apprend plus tard donc c'est des
couteaux qui peuvent passer 100 200 ans
facilement si on et d'entretien
je m'appelle marie dô au fleury je suis
décoratrice sur porcelaine j'ai débuté
en 1996 en autodidacte et en 1998 j'ai
pu acheter mon tout premier four 99 j'ai
pu participer à mon premier fait main
avec l'association arts et traditions
ça m'a servi en quelque sorte de
tremplin j'ai pu présenter mes produits
et voir si ça plaisait ça m'a encouragé
donc aller de plus en plus loin et donc
j'achète de la vaisselle blanche en
porcelaine parfois dugré parfois de la
faïence et pour décorer donc ces pièces
en porcelaine
on utilise des pigments qui sont des
oxydes de minéraux broyer ses pigments
ces poudres sont préparés avec un médium
qui est un mélange de thé léventine
fluide et de térébenthine épaissi le
décor est entièrement peints à la main
au pinceau parfois à l'épongé
on laisse sécher et on pourra le passé
donc en cuisson et donc à 8 150 degrés
le brillant de la porcelaine est en
fusion les la peinture le décor qu'on a
peint dessus est également en fusion et
au refroidissement ça sera complètement
intégré l'un dans l'autre comme une
vitrification c'est inaltérable ça
craint le couteau bien sûr donc c'est un
manipuler quand même avec précaution
mais ça passe en lave vaisselle ça passe
au four pour un gratin pour chauffer une
assiette ça passe au four micro-ondes et
fours traditionnels
ce qui plaît une année ne plaira pas
forcément l'année suivante il faut tout
le temps se renouveler tout le temps
essayer de trouver de nouvelles idées de
manière à ce que les gens aient
l'impression de nous re découvrir à
chaque fois les gens savent que
lorsqu'on me commande quelque chose je
vais prendre le temps qu'il faut mais ça
sera soigné est le plus parfait possible
déjà rien que le fait de que la personne
me disent que ça lui plaît et que c'est
beau c'est quelque chose qui est déjà
très important pour moi
m